[Music]
if you're thinking about it we're
talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi I'm Rosanna Lockwood on uncensored
tonight the first migrants arrive on the
so-called Bibby Stockholm barge
following weeks of delays some 15 men
were greeted by campaigners bearing
gifts as they finally move on to the
dorset-based boat but as the government
strategy sustainable or doomed to
failure we're going to be debating that
well bringing in the big guns as the
electioneers kirst armor enlists Tony
Blair to help turn the labor party's
fortunes around so is it time for Blair
the sequel or does his legacy mean he
should be left behind by labor and after
a whistleblower told Congress the U.S is
concealing a multi-decade program that
captured UFOs our world governments
going to have to come clean about
extraterrestrial contact here on Earth
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored with me Rosanna
lock we're back in the chair for another
week for peers now the Women's World Cup
it's almost halfway through have you
watched any matches if you haven't I
will excuse you because it is of course
being hosted by Australia New Zealand
this year so the games are a little bit
out of our time zone aren't they but do
you support the players anyway our very
own lionesses from England they've
reached the quarterfinals meanwhile
reigning Champs the US are out after a
penalty shootout with Sweden there's
been drama there's been high stakes
competitions skill and grit across the
board and yet still we must hear these
debates every time there's a women's
football tournament about whether we
should actually be taking it seriously
whether it's as important or as gripping
as the men's World Cup and I understand
football is typically a man's world it's
a safe space to be one of always
depreciate the Brilliance of the play I
admire it too so perhaps men who try to
deny or undermine the quality of women's
football feel like their male space is
being invaded they want to keep that
corner for themselves in a world which
feels like it's increasingly
prioritizing the rights of women and
others over men and a part of me
actually I can understand that but one
thing I cannot understand is this in the
endless fiery debates about trans rights
at the moment where men are often some
of the loudest voices especially on
calling for trans women to be banned
from women's sports are those same Men
actually supporting women's sports when
it comes down to it or are those same
men perhaps joking about skill level and
sports bras and saying women's football
can never be as competitive or as
entertaining as the men's game that all
I'm saying is this if you feel very
strongly about women having Fair and
competitive Sports whether that be tied
to transgender debates or not then put
your money where your mouth is and
support our women athletes because
there's honestly nothing you stand to
lose from doing so yes we are getting
good at it but we can't compete against
you on the same pitch in the same game
just yet so let's just accept that both
things can exist and both can be done
well and let's support our nation's best
whether it be at home in the pub online
or in conversation because it all counts
of course now on this topic join me
fresh from Australia is talksport
presenter Shaban Ahern thank you so much
for making time probably a little bit
jet lagged and I want to start because
the religious listening to me sort of
opening the show there I want to say
that actually peers who I'm obviously
sitting in for I'm not saying this just
to Delight him I doubt he's watching I
hope he's on holiday but of course he is
somebody who's spoken about about trans
rights and women's sports and the rest
of it and he does support women's
football he's been talking about it a
lot he's released a com column today
about it in fact
um and I just want to ask you a little
bit about that topic he's brought up in
this column which is the activism well
this is actually something that Trump's
also said as well that activism is
getting in the way of the US campaign
because the U.S team didn't go as far as
far as people would like and some saying
there were two focused on activism what
do you make of that
well credit to you on how you opened
your show there I have to say I've
thoroughly enjoyed hearing that because
in the last 24 hours the the abuse that
Megan rapino gets uh from you know her
own USA fans now off the back of the
actors activism and the support she has
the trans Community for the lgbtq
community it's actually refreshing to
sit here and go actually everybody
should just get behind female athletes
athletes football and sport is a place
for everyone now I was reading through
Piers Morgan's tweets and I'm like what
is your obsession why does Trump hate
Megan rapping her so much why do peers
hate Megan Rapinoe so much and why they
feel they're doing the right thing for
everybody to have a place in sport why
do so many people have an issue with
that I have no idea because we cannot
relate to what they're going through I
don't think that trans athletes decide
to be trans because they've got more of
more of an opportunity to do well as
women in sport do you not think they've
battled enough for themselves do not
think they've gone through enough
hardship and pain and suffering to find
a place in a community where they'll be
accepted for who they are so never mind
to have trolls on the internet giving it
and shocking it because because they're
they're male they're dominant they've
got that power they've got followers
they can influence people so much I just
find it so
oh and exhausting and then I look at
peers and I think but he seems to love
watching the lionesses so just leave it
you know you don't have to get involved
in something that you really don't know
enough about he knows enough about sport
he supports England and whatever they
seem to do but I do have an issue with
that have an issue with going for people
who have their own battles and their own
struggles who are just going about their
business and Megan rap and I was
speaking up for those communities I get
that for sure it's in the right place
uh thank you for your comments I'm
slightly wide now peers is watching this
because I think he's gonna have some
things to say you might be finding
yourself invited back into the studio to
meet him head-on um you made some very
clear points though you got your point
across I do want to just quickly talk to
you before we go to the panelist studio
about the Women's World Cup what's going
down in Australia and New Zealand
currently did you feel like uh there's a
Groundswell of support for the women
over there and do you think the
lionesses can go far
sorry went down the rabbit hole that's
what I do
um yeah no absolutely listen being out
there I spent a lot of time in Brisbane
and it was phenomenal you know they've
really embraced it the fan parts have
been absolutely outstanding the travel
and support I mean the money it costs to
go to any tournament never mind all the
way to Australia to travel around and
support your teams you know whatever it
is they're going to be I went to started
in Sydney then to Brisbane then to Perth
and back to Brisbane it costs a fortune
and fans are doing it I think it's a
huge change for women's football the
fact that that the fans have gone to so
much effort to make sure they have been
there regardless the traveling support's
been incredible I think the lionesses
yes can go all the way I am absolutely
mind blown from what happened in the
game against Nigeria today and on paper
I was going okay England have this down
I've watched enough in Nigeria I thought
they were tired and their final group
came against Ireland and I thought it
would be a walk in the park for England
now that was ignorant by the way that
was ignorant for me to think that I
think they've been phenomenal on this
tournament England are lucky to be
through but they have that panel tissue
I've experience right they've done that
before we saw it in the phenylissima
against Brazil they have a Winner's
mentality as well but now they're
without Lord and James for the next
couple of games and that could be a
problem because for me she was their
star so I read today lost her head she
will regret that for a long long time it
was fascinating that number seven shirt
as well thank you very much for giving
us your insights to your knowledge
expertise and your opinion strong
opinion to open the show with tonight
thank you well let us introduce this
story to our pack as well they were
listening in they were hooked associate
editor of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
talk TV contributor Esther kraku and
Grace Blakely the Socialist commentator
and author thanks the three of you for
joining us uh what did you make of that
Kevin
well I watched the game I start I really
enjoyed it uh England were outclassed
outplayed we got through on this at the
skin of that Ethan and Lauren James just
you know getting sent off and deservedly
so just shows how competitive uh it is
but look you can't you can't take
politics and policies out of sport
they've always mixed I mean it's always
been the case I remember the
um I'm old enough the opposition to the
white supremacist tourists from South
Africa rugby and Cricket 1969 and 70
very successful campaigns uh against
them Olympic boycotts all you go and
people are gonna women are going to
spittle because I don't want to be
another one of those men shouting here
but women are going to speak up for
trans women in sport or against them
around that issue of biological sex it's
going to divide women it's gonna divide
players but I don't see what the point
of having to go at them politics has
always been in Sport AS Kevin says you
know does it distract players
unnecessarily well yes especially when
you lose because then people are going
to say if you focus on playing the game
instead of your activism you may have
won and I think Megan Rapinoe has made a
reputation for herself just you know
ruffling feathers in that way I would
say I didn't watch the game I actually
don't watch women's before I I I if you
watch men's football yes I do I watch
women's sports I watch mainly Athletics
and gymnastics so I do support I guess
support women's sports I just I just
don't like watching women's football
because I'm used to watching men's
football I think the pictures are too
big for the women I think seriously no
no like when I see that on the bench
they look like they look like children
to me I'm like you need to drink that
much smaller than that there was a
debate there was a debate about reducing
the goals let me finish when you look at
like the female goalkeepers in in in in
in the net they look like children
because they're they're you know they
are just not as large so I think you
need to shrink it down because it's more
challenging and more skills
I think we're missing we're missing the
point here massively which is the okay
so my niece
um is currently working as a coach she
coaches a men's
um a young men's football team near
where we live and she was telling me
about all of the massive barriers she
faced to getting to into her career
where she is now and how difficult it's
been she played football
um for a while and then got herself into
this position and she said watching the
women at the Euros watching the
lionesses seeing this huge support that
the country had for that team was really
transformational for her not just in
thinking oh maybe I can do this but
actually in the way that she was treated
by her peers so I think we really have
to think about not just you know who's
watching the people at the top we also
think about how this is trickling down
the the
comparison that's been drawn here do you
know how difficult it is to become a
successful men's football player I mean
your odds of even getting on a team how
many players on the the but I mean
that's the point because you know there
is obviously there's a difference
between there being a difficulty
resulting from the competitiveness of
the sport and that being a difficulty
resulting from people placing barriers
to your progression
but that doesn't make sense because
hold on the whole point of football is
based on skills with only discrimination
you're going to get is if you're not but
I was just literally saying that like my
cousin who works in this area has had
difficulties because they're because you
shouldn't be doing this because it's
very different to say they are female
football players hold on she's very good
enough to make a national team fight
final a final point from each of you and
then we'll move on you you do you feel
yourself I mean the thing is listen I'm
happy that women's football is is
getting the attention that deserves and
the funding and you know more and more
people are interested in watching it I
don't think that drawing a binary
between saying that actually women's
football should be for biological women
is the same as you know trying to
exclude people I mean that's literally
what it's called women's football I
think on the point that someone like
Megan rapino is getting a lot of you
know hatred because of her activism well
yes and especially because she lost
because if you're going to be an
activist and you lose well that's a
double I think that we've always had
this argument that anyone who engages in
what we call politics I.E sticking up
for the people who are like them in
their store gets in the way of the sport
and actually they're only doing this
because they're not very good it's just
a way of basically protecting the status
quo it's a way of saying especially at
the lower rungs of the sport which are
perhaps less visible in the public where
you're going to get more kind of a lady
culture and people being excluded it's a
way of saying to people this is not for
people like you without talking of Lady
culture let's watch a lad uh in his
prime I hope you've had uh or hadn't had
your supper yet or your dinner yet
because uh hold your breath watch this
[Music]
oh girl that is uh the of course Matt
Hancock the one and only displaying
what's known as his Ken a g that's Ken
from Barbie he's miming to a song from
the Barbie movie in case you haven't
seen it called I'm just Ken on a beach I
just don't know why the man has is
having a midlife crisis doesn't he can
somebody has somebody just give him a
job or put him in a box I mean it is I
mean it's just ludicrous I mean is he
trying to be as bad as he comes across
as well there's no self-awareness I mean
that you had almost offered him a joke
but then he blew that yeah
is that I
I just know self-awanna
's Shameless but even if he's completely
aware of how terrible he looks doing all
of this stuff he's all obviously just
desperate for attention the thing is
people like myself
but people like Matt Hancock great on me
for a different reason he is part of the
reason why politics is seen as is not as
respected or politicians and that's the
reason I don't care that he's doing this
cringe-worthy stuff I care that someone
like him as you know sitting MP could
have gone on a reality TV show and felt
no shame about it well the more that
should be bad the more celebrities that
end up in the jungle the more because
sorry still every politicians end up in
the jungle of course the more we could
be seeing it and more uh politicians
rumored ex Prime Ministers and the light
now talking of the Barbie movie the
Barbie movie has grossed a billion
dollars at the box office that is a it's
a female director uh it makes her the
first solo female director filmmaker
with a billion dollar film uh other hits
from the studio as well Warner Brothers
is of course
um they've had Harry Potter and
everything but this is one the fastest
17 days it took to grow some billion
dollars and we just want to remind you
that some people in the media uh were
called the Barbie whingers they didn't
believe this movie would be a success
they thought it was an attacking on men
on the patriarchy they thought it was
offensive uh let's take a listen to them
the thing is just a mess it doesn't make
any sense and literally the only way you
can have a happy world is if the women
ignore the man and the men ignore the
women that seems to be the the final
outcome of this film all men in the film
are either bigots or idiots now is
Barbie a smash the patriarchy feminist
film yes it is the real world and all
the men in it are shown to be
universally irredeemably horrible
that sort of strikes me uh Kevin I'll
come to you in all of this is that all
the critics who said it wouldn't grow to
a billion dollars seem to have forgotten
that half of the world's population is
females even if no men go and watch it
you're still gonna get her I know this
bloke went to watch it but who says
feminism doesn't pay
change first of all that's complete as a
lifelong Bobby fan I will say two things
first of all this film had the the the
the the brand to to fall back on this
the Barbie film has had over 40 animated
films and hundreds of of of books
released about it it had a huge fan base
it's had a fan base since the 1960s so
they obviously had you know they were
propelled by the brand franchise
in real life secondly the production
budget was actually less than the
marketing budget so that just goes to
show if you have a massive brand and you
can pump a lot of money into your
marketing it doesn't matter if you've
created a trash heap of the film which
is what it was and I will forever stand
by that
and I still haven't seen
I kind of don't plan to go and see it
oh I know that everyone is obsessed with
this idea and thinks that it's like a a
feminist epic but again it's not my kind
of feminism like what for me well you
might smile and enjoy it
okay that we're gonna dismantle the
patriarchy and deal with all of these
issues that we discussed so much in the
show by having like some female CEOs or
like a film done by a woman that makes a
billion dollars is absurd I don't think
anybody's arguing I don't think
anybody's arguing that though it wasn't
a feminism it was a satire of some sort
of feminist Abomination now we don't
necessarily agree on anything a lot of
things but
but
we do have some overlap in our
frustrations with regards to how you
know the issue of feminism is dealt with
particularly in the Western World we
used to call them like Western idealist
feminists or whatever we call them and
you have a point I actually
unfortunately have seen the film so a
lot of your concerns are valid it's not
a feminism it is it it is just
piggybacking off the master plan that is
Barbie on that bombshell on that
bombshell we have to wrap it there but
thank you for opening the show for us
panel Monday night pack lots of
entertainment there now I'm standing
next tonight we will be taking that a
bit more seriously migrants have ordered
the baby Stockholm barge endorse it
after weeks with delays but with over 15
000 people arriving illegally to the UK
so far this year how will barge with a
capacity of just 500 sold the
ever-growing crisis that's coming up
next
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
back in the chat now after weeks of
delays the first migrants are finally
aboard What's called the Bibby Stockholm
barge around 15 male Asylum Seekers
boarded the barge earlier today as the
government tries to find a solution to
the immigration crisis one migrant
charity has branded the barge a
quasi-floating prison the Rwanda plan of
course bogged down in the courts and
more than 15 000 crossing the channel so
far this year the situation has become
so convoluted in fact that even a small
island in the South Atlantic look at
where that is
is room to be the next place that the UK
could send migrants who've illegally
crossed the channel well joining me to
discuss all of this former brexit party
MEP Ben Habib Crescent Esther cracky
rather sorry joins me still here in the
studio and from Portland in Dorset where
the barge is docked Daniel Sands joins
us from the campaign group no to the
barge Daniel uh let's start with you
then you've been there today what have
you observed
yeah good evening so um there's been an
awful lot of movement at the Port today
um I was up at the uh a cafe overlooking
the area uh for around two hours
he had a lot of buses coming and going
but didn't see an awful lot of people
actually getting on the barge if I'm
honest
um I hear not as many have got on as
they should all yeah which has been an
odd situation because
um some in government might call that a
disappointment others of course in
society wouldn't call it that much
because the barge has been criticized
for being against human rights by many
quarters let's bring in our studio
guests as well on this Esther and Ben in
the studio as as uh British people as
people heavily involved in politics just
quite simply I want to start off by ask
you Ben how comfortable are you with the
idea of having migrants housed in these
rooms on a barge well I I I find the
whole debate a big digression you know
the at most this barge could take 500
people that's four days worth of intake
on average about 100 odd people are
coming across the channel each day the
barge is a red herring but we can't even
get the barge right you know people
refuse to go on the bars today for fear
of being on water did you hear that
Rosanna I mean you couldn't make this up
can't independently confirmed that
either but no I didn't hear that well
that's what I've been reading that one
of the claims that care for Calais made
which is a charitable organization that
mounted a legal challenge but part of
the legal challenge was the fact that
people couldn't bear to be on water they
were traumatized by water I mean they're
just literally An Inconvenient trip
across the channel I know very
inconvenient and if you're coming if
they originally came from Libya or
somewhere like that can you imagine the
trauma they must have gone through to
get to Italy well I think I'm assuming
that's their point I mean the issue here
I mean the the Portland
um mayor was saying that the barges are
uncomfortable because the rooms are too
small I think there's like sides of a
parking space is what I've heard exactly
and she said the bunk beds are only
about six feet long so if you're taller
than six feet it's uncomfortable and all
of that but I think there's there's an
element of of being tone deaf that we're
we're witnessing here the reality is
there are thousands of homeless people
in this country that have been homeless
many of whom are men right you cannot
justify keeping these people in hotel
rooms while saying that actually if you
can make accommodations so quickly for
people that are here albeit under
different circumstances then that need
to be processed quickly we now need to
be concerned about whether their bunk
beds are six feet or six so that there
there is a migrant issue there's Channel
Crossings there's thousands
yes there are homeless people in this
country but there are also people
arriving all the time but the 500
people's barge ain't gonna solve the
problem of course and and this barge by
the way I mean it looks really fancy
it's got a snooker table it's got a
built-in gym it's got 24 7 Medical Care
would you stay there Ben you have time
well I'm not an illegal migrant I pay my
taxes and I've you know paid them all my
life and I've been privileged enough and
lucky enough to make enough money to
live so you came from a war-torn country
like Syria yeah and you've traveled a
long time to get somewhere and you were
denied entry immediately and you put on
the barge do you think you could live
there comfortably whilst waiting I would
be utterly delighted to be in that barge
if I came from Warsaw awesome
Let's cross back to Daniel sands on this
because it almost feels like no quarters
of the migrant uh complex issue that
we've got going on in the United Kingdom
will be satisfied by anything as we've
heard from the studio it's a red herring
some are saying the barge we've got this
Ascension Island planned as well also
could be argued a hollow threat or a red
herring
um whatever happens it will be too
comfortable or not enough uh Daniel but
what is the solution then to the UK
migrant issue
well the the question the we keeping
back to us as you know Lodge is is who
is this actually good for
and then ultimately
who is it good for at the moment well it
seemingly nobody the government's own uh
argument that this is cheaper than
hotels is completely out the window uh
and it seems like there's just a
complete blank check uh but the home
office is going to keep throwing at this
and unlimited resources
um and ultimately it's not up to us to
have the solution we are
we should be in a position as a society
to object an idea about having to have
the answer it's no good to say you have
to accept this bad if I'm sorry if you
if you're not providing any solutions
why have you created this campaign group
surely you're just wasting your time
I don't believe we're wasting our time
to object something that we morally
object to I mean how is that wasting
your time but why don't you offer any
solutions we all live in a society ideas
are welcome if you have no ideas then
why are you just making noise
it's a slightly off-paced uh analogy so
forgive me but if I was desperate for a
toilet
um and the only place I could go I would
recommend you find one that's right I I
could not go there and say
well I'm sorry that I used your front
doorstep but I couldn't find a toilet
that's your problem yes I will provide
you many solutions in the back of a car
park for instance I would never say
something without offering a solution
because that's not that doesn't benefit
anyone in the public discourse
but it's no you cannot say that it's
okay to accept a bad solution because we
cannot come up with it what is bad what
are you comparing it to you haven't
offered any viable Alternatives so bad
is it doesn't mean anything
the alternative that the government is
comparing this to is hotels right and
they're saying and I'm not defending the
government but there is an argument to
say that by keeping these people on a
barge which I'm not saying is
necessarily the optimal solution you're
keeping them out of neighborhoods for
instance which is where these hotels are
and there's also a security component so
there's so many hold on there's so many
migrants that have been allowed to to
enter British society that haven't been
tracked we don't know where they are for
goodness sake and so the argument is by
keeping them in these Close Quarters you
can keep a better eye on them my point
is what is your solution what Solutions
are you offering since you've you know
you're you're heading this campaign
group against these barges
well the firstly to to answer the false
uh claim that just made that these
people have been held on the barge
they're not they are free to come and go
as they please they're yes
they're not you know in the middle of
nowhere no no they cannot be tracked
they are being asked to return at a
certain time but that that's it there is
no curfew
pardon but we we know who they are it's
not like they're just having a bunch of
random people on the budget there is a
system that's actually recorded who is
on I want to come back to Ben in the
studio and just ask a little bit about
where this leaves uh Britain in terms of
a perception point of view because
that's the big question because the only
kind of likeness I could think of when I
thought about the bar Australia has had
similar offshore immigration schemes
with islands in the past they've been
condemned as being like concentration
camps According to some human rights
groups uh Australia has a very tight and
strictly controlled immigration system
um do you think that's done them any ill
will so let's let's just get one thing
straight the government's entire policy
on the illegal Crossings of the channel
is what they call through deterrence and
initially pretty Patel came up with the
nationality and borders bill which he
said would sort the problem it became an
act it didn't Rwanda was going to sort
the problem
um the illegal migration bill they say
will sort the problem let me tell you it
will not because there is a car like for
the European Court of Human Rights and
all the treatment they get when they
come to the United Kingdom isn't a
different League to what they get in
France which is why of course so many
wish to come here we are not practicing
any form of deterrence the minute they
enter our territorial Waters they have a
warm blanket put around them a cup of
tea given them in their hands put
temporarily up in a four-star hotel
possibly in Pimlico and then move to a
barge which the human rights people are
up in arms about but actually I would be
perfectly comfortable there if I'd come
from war-torn Syria the point about what
I'm getting to is that the emperor has
no clothes Rishi sunak
cannot deter people from crossing the
Channel all his policies have turned out
to be a fast we might as well call this
a carry-on migration of that fantastic
series of comedy films of the 1970s
because that's where our policies left
us carry on I see we're going on with
that you know and it's a smart analogy
but of course humans involved here uh
you know and they are coming from
difficult situations and whilst I agree
with you about the government and the
the mess up I think in the long-term
policy of this and it's going to be
fascinating to see how they can hang on
to this until the next election at the
same time I think a lot of British
people would say putting a blanket
around somebody who's been in a boat at
Sea and maybe it's been at the heart
hands of criminal gangs who've got them
there isn't the worst thing I mean
that's not I would agree with you that I
don't necessarily object to them it's
been shown as a bit of a hospital
hospitable treatment
um particularly since they've made the
trip across the channel which I
personally wouldn't do I think the
bigger issue is the the what is that the
core of this problem is the broken
Asylum system the fact that we can't
process these people fast enough the
fact that I actually think really you
know they're people that are in a worse
situation that don't have money to you
know pay people Smugglers or get across
the channel that are being ignored or
can't even have access to our Asylum
system because there's a bottleneck now
with all these people rushing in you
know we can't process them quickly
enough and we're effectively ignoring
the people that really should probably
get priority to even be on the Asylum
you know well I mean I mean that's a
bigger issue for me you know they're all
coming from France they're all safe well
I mean they've all had their security
assured this is by any definition this
is economic migration that's what it is
and I would take a much harder line I'm
afraid Esther we have an international
right under the UN Convention of law of
the sea to deter and to use whatever
preventative means we need to use in
order to protect our borders and to
prevent illegal entry and Border Force
needs to do its job it needs to use the
international law at our disposal to
turn these boats around that's what
Australia did and it worked in Australia
it sounds very
very build a wall it is in force your
borders it's what we would have done at
any moment in history until this
complete collapse and political world
that seems to have gripped modern
Britain well it's certainly clear that
in the United Kingdom today whilst there
a lot of people would agree that there
is an issue regarding the number of
people coming into the country and those
illegally doing so there is a wide range
of views and we've had them this evening
thank you very much to Ben Habib Esther
kraku and Daniel Sands joining us down
the line from Portland Dorset as well
now nonsense next Tonight Tony Blair the
sequel could the former labor prime
minister be the answer to Sir kids
dharma's prayers and help the party win
the next election we'll debate that next
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah pink pears and
King Q I think it's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
they're skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war remember me cry again they're trying
to force you out yes I feel betrayed
keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
consolid party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
stop producing oil the knock-on effect
is far larger than just CO2 I nearly
have empathy when I'm speaking to them I
know you're probably going to vote me
off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
[Music]
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back now here in the UK as
labors start gearing up the next general
election attention now focused on party
leader sakir starmer and his chances of
taking that top PM job often criticized
for hypocrisy and lacking Clarity it
seems he's looking to the former leader
and three-time election winner sir Tony
Blair for direction now recently in
their first public appearance together
Blair effectively gave starmer his
handshake of approval
well you know it's uh
how far you've taken the labor party in
the last
four years as any guide to how far you
can take the country will be in good
hands
thank you
a bit of a labor love in there Blair had
his fair share of controversy of course
over the years and the scars of the Iraq
War still Loom large so is it a good
move for secure starma we're going to
debate that now joined in the studio
Again by socialist Norther Grace Blakely
down the line by former labor party MP
Stephen pound who did actually serve
under Tony Blair also joining us labor
counselor and momentum member Martin
Abrams let's uh start with you Stephen
if you don't mind seeing as you served
under the man himself do you think it
would be a good thing for us to have
Blair back on the scene I think it'll be
absolutely marvelous uh but for two
reasons yeah one is there's a slight
Oddity in the world what does an
ex-president or an ex-prime Minister do
um and you you can either be like sort
of Gordon Brown like a you know a
prophet crying in the wilderness or you
know or you fade away you know like uh
David Cameron did with a lot of rather
dodgy business people I think uh Jimmy
Carter is probably the only National
figure apart from Tony Blair who's
actually made something of the you know
life after power so it once you accept
they've got to do something you then
come to what actually Tony Bear is doing
the single most important thing in
politics is to avoid getting away to
avoid the nonsense of short-termism and
there's a great many politicians are so
risk-averse they dare not ask the big
questions and the biggest question in
the world today is how we in the
developing West can actually work with
the developing world when it comes to
global warming and that's what Tony
Blair's asking the question for as he
was at this Tony Blair Institute uh
conference they had last week so he's in
a unique position he still has the
ability a sort of hypnotic ability that
he displayed so brilliantly on three
three general elections to somehow
actually articulate and speak these huge
issues so we welcome him back because
you know we do actually need somebody
who's got the ideas who can look over
the horizon someone who yes absolutely
fraud of course he's flawed you know
there's never been one perfect human
being on the face of the Earth all the
rest of us are flawed but I welcome him
back because he brings energy he brings
ideas but above all yeah he brings a
global perspective on global problems uh
Stephen you raised a lot of things there
including the fact that of course Blair
no no you know your major case uh very
clearly Blair has been enormously
successful post prime minister she was
multi-millionaire he's got this Tony
Blair Institute for Global change which
could be called a sort of soft power
international policy initiative
um and he consults a lot and the rest of
it but at the same time I'll come to you
Martin uh I I think we're about the same
age I'm making assumptions here but when
I hear the name Tony Blair there was one
thing I associate with associate him
with unfortunately in most prime
minister remember one thing and that is
the Iraq War and it's hard for many
people under the age of 35 to forget
that isn't it
absolutely and Tony Blair cannot Escape
The Haunting Specter of the Iraq War
which led to the deaths of hundreds of
thousands of people the displacement of
millions of refugees it devastated
Iraq's infrastructure in society and
essentially it fostered a lethal
sectarianism that ultimately turned into
a civil war spreading terrorism across
the region and across much of the globe
so this really feels like an absolutely
bizarre approach for kirst armor to be
kind of welcoming Tony Blair back into
the fold because let's face it Tony
Blair is politically toxic he is the
least popular
um living labor leader currently
um you know pulling well below
um people like Gordon Brown and Jeremy
corbyn and uh let's remember his 20
years since the Iraq War now and recent
Google poll published on the the 20th
anniversary found a fifth of Britain's
think Tony Blair knowingly misled
Parliament over the Iraq War and should
be tried as a war criminal one-fifth of
all britons believe that let's get it's
incredible that it's even being
considered being allowed back into the
party level mine back into you know the
the Inner Circle of Care starmer Stephen
I will come back to a few reaction but
let's cost a great in the studio then
and talk about the fact that yes okay
Tony Blair has got this sort of uh
glowing rhetorical style you know
they've seen what the fact that the
speech you did recently you know he's a
brilliant speaker can he turn that
reputation around given what we just
heard from Martin the facts that stand
as well about their art War
I think you know this debate about Tony
Blair often comes down to uh well you
know he he won three elections versus he
did the Iraq War and actually there's a
lot more to discuss about Tony Blair
both in and out of office
um and also we need to compare that in
reality to what we can see in case
Dharma so Blair's policy agenda for
example it rested a lot on kind of you
know we talked about climate change
bringing the private sector into uh the
response to climate breakdown which
again we've seen hasn't work it was a
lot to do with kind of deregulation
deregulating for finance sector famously
which helps to lead up to the crisis of
2008 and since he left office he's been
learning as you said millions
um going around the world often
Consulting with authoritarian
governments um to make that money now
there's a lot to critique about Blair
but I also think it's worth you know
looking dispassionately at his record
and saying yes he did win three
elections and he did come in onto the
political scene with some very clear
ideas a sense of we're going to change
things this kind of obama-esque
excitement a very good kind of
rhetorical style and care biggest armor
has a lot of those policies and none of
the rhetorical flourish he has he's
basically backed by the same wing of the
labor party which of course why Blair is
supporting him but he doesn't have that
same Charisma he doesn't have the same
values it's really just very difficult
to say what he even stands for which is
why Actually I don't even think even
though I don't approve of most of what
Tony Blair did I don't even think
kistama is as good as Tony Blair Let's
cross back to Stephen and ask you you've
heard all of that you heard the case put
forward by Grace by uh Martin as well
and obviously the fact you know about
already do you think that changes uh the
mood onto in terms of whether Blair will
be accepted back into modern British
Society because times have moved on well
I I hope people could actually see Tony
Blair's career so far in the round I I'm
here in Ealing in my old constituency
just over the road there's three kosovar
families and their eldest sons have all
been called Tony Blair because that's
the names of their children because
they're so grateful for what Tony Blair
did in the South Balkans and and don't
forget he also did the same thing in
Sierra Leone in East Timor and when it
comes to be coming up a pro and
anti-list you know pros and cons of Tony
Blair you know minimum wage Equalization
of the age of consent I can give you I
think about 65 really really good pieces
of Education whether they stack up
against Iraq I don't know I'm not
prepared to say that I can't sit in
judgment on that all I can say is that
that Tony Blair is a man of energy and
intelligence and articulate you can
articulate ideals in a way that we need
it but I guess back back to my basic
Point politicians are terrified of
actually committing themselves they're
the big big picture no politician really
in my lifetime has actually done that
because they just don't want to actually
look at the global issues they are
obsessed with the parochial impetus but
that's the important thing Tony Blair is
a stepping outside electoral politics
and is actually looking at that big
picture be grateful sorry can I come
back quickly on that point about Kosovo
and Sierra Leone in Iraq because I don't
know about you guys I have actually read
Tony Blair's autobiography found it
absolutely fascinating not least because
of the kind of Evangelical Zeal with
which he appeared to approach all of
these foreign interventions and you can
see as he moved from one to the next
from Kosovo to Sierra Leone
um two Easter more to Iraq there's this
sense that he's going to basically save
the world and I actually think that's
why he ended up making a lot of mistakes
in Iraq I actually think that's why it's
difficult even for him to look back to
his passionately over the course of his
career and I think that was really why
he became such a toxic figure in
politics and why he's still it I want to
give Martin just we've only got about 20
seconds left Martin I'm sorry to run out
of time like this but if not Tony Blair
would it be care starmer your vote
well listen castama needs to remember
what platform he stood on during his
leadership election with the labor party
members he needs to he needs to stand on
a platform of public ownership of
anti-austerity you know we need to look
forward and we need a little bit of hope
we desperately need a little bit of Hope
people
election a hopeless general election so
reject the politics of the past and Tony
Blair and let's look forward and let's
have a hopeful uh future hope hope is
good hope I can get behind look the
three of you thank you very much for a
very interesting discussion on the
return or the possible return of Blair
now uncensored next tonight
whistleblowers in the U.S say the
government have been operating a secret
program to capture and reverse engineer
alien life for years so is it time for
governments to Fed Up about all of the
Extraterrestrial encounters we'll be
debating that next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk the government's
controversial Bibby Stockholm barge
welcomes its first migrant residence Liz
truss's resignation honors list hits the
headlines as it's vetoed by members of
the House of Lords and Harry and Megan
could be coming to a big screen near you
after the couple by the movie rights for
a romantic novel that's all at nine
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood in the chair this
Monday night it might be time to grab
your tinfoil hats because the aliens are
coming and apparently a lot of them
they've been almost 1 000 documented UFO
sightings in the UK since January 2021
and they even seem to be targeting
certain areas of the UK more than others
with most sightings taking place in
Greater Manchester London and Chester
now at the end of July three former
military officials in the U.S told
Congress they believe aliens are real
and the government are purposely
concealing evidence a Former
Intelligence official went on record to
say the US government is in possession
of non-human biological remains
if you believe we have crashed craft uh
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots who piloted this craft
biologics came with some of these
recoveries yeah were they I guess human
or non-human biologics non-human and
that was the assessment of people with
direct knowledge on the program I talked
to that are currently still on the
program
so should we all be gearing up for an
alien invasion or is it all a bit of a
conspiracy joining me now to discuss all
this UFO ologist and host of weaponized
podcast Jeremy Corbell and UFO expert
the one who investigated UFOs for the US
Ministry of Defense Nick Pope gentlemen
thank you Nick I'll start with you uh
you were the person who obtained and
released the military filmed Pentagon
confirmed UFO videos that put into
motion the First Congressional hearings
on UFOs no 50 years and the recent
hearings as well you were part of that
so I mean it when we approached this
topic people can get a bit silly about
it you know we had the X-Files music
talk about alien invasions but this is
very much your career your life's work
do you think people take it seriously
enough
well they do in the United States sure
we've just had these Congressional
hearings and uh you know this this
person David grush who's testified was
verifiably part of the unidentified
aerial phenomena Task Force if he was
making this up he would be committing a
federal offense by the way because this
was under oath he has apparently given
the Senate intelligence committee the
house intelligence committee and the
Inspector General of the intelligence
Community a very specific checkable
facts project names locations a list of
people who are prepared to testify this
is being taken very very seriously now
as a defense and national security issue
in the United States and it's it's a
long time that the British government
reopened their UFO program by the way
that was terminated at the end of 2009
indeed and Jeremy rather sorry I should
I think I misnamed you at the start
there in terms of the recent
Congressional hearings that we heard in
the US what struck me most was that it
was announced but to very little Fanfare
people didn't seem to care it's almost
like they've been through a pandemic and
there's a war going on and the price of
everything is through the roof and uh
Alien suddenly aren't that interesting
or worrisome to them anymore
well first of all that's incorrect and
hello Nick nice to see you this is a
completely different situation than is
being shown right here you said put on
your tinfoil hats people should put on
their battle helmets right now this is
being taken seriously from the world
public it's a serious topic and people
need to understand why it's a serious
Topic at this time right now you've been
told something historic you've been told
something historic from your government
you've been told something historic from
my government right now what you've been
told is that UFOs are indeed real that
there is a technological aspect to it
and the world needs to catch up with
consensus reality it is being taken very
seriously at the highest levels of
government and for reasons that are
really good one is strategic surprise
it's really simple to understand that if
somebody has technology that we don't
have that can outpace outmaneuver and
outperform our greatest fighter planes
and Weapons Systems like Commander David
fraver who testified at that hearing
told you then this is something that it
should be understood differently than
how it's being presented right now well
you've got an opportunity to respond to
that
yeah I do no I
this is this is all absolutely serious I
I mean a few a few months ago this sort
of thing would have been maybe just
dismissed but now it's been discussed in
the United States Congress in the
scientific and academic Community there
is I think a growing realization that
this is real and there are going to be
more things coming in the next few weeks
and months by the way NASA is doing a
study as we speak they're going to
report uh later this month there will be
more hearings in the United States
Congress and there will be more
whistleblowers coming forward speaking
out on the record under oath on the
floor of Congress this is a fact
Jeremy is is there an extent to the
amount of information that normal people
can handle is there an argument the
government should withhold some
information
the poison right now is the lack of
information and the lack of proper
reporting on this the only remedy and
the only cure is to inform the American
and Global public we are living in a
data-rich environment when it comes to
foes or UAP as you say but that the real
danger is secrecy and lack of
transparency and what Nick said is
correct and I know because I've directly
spoken with the witnesses that have
already taken action that is not yet
public to come forward and America will
lead by example as we do at our greatest
moments in history but this is not an
American issue this is a global issue
it's not just bipartisan and that's why
you see AOC and representative Tim
birchett leading the charge here from
people who are under oath who have been
designated to protect our national
interests as well as our Global
interests and we need to really look at
how we treat David grush right now
because these hearings this historic
hearings that you saw was the first time
in history that people are talking with
first-hand information where they
directly engaged UFOs in a combat
situation as well as in training times
so what we see right now is an embolding
and an empowering of people who desire
to come forward because it is the right
the just the ethical and the legal thing
to do but we need to see how David grush
who is the only whistleblower that was
standing up there the other two people
they were just testifying George Knapp
and I my mentor on journalism we also
put something on Congressional Record so
that the public would be informed I
should look at that both of you thank
you very much for your time we've
learned quite a bit there about UFOs and
aliens that is it from us this evening
whatever you're up to make sure it's
uncensored and we'll be back here same
time tomorrow good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
wall this is making me cry again I'm
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears to
be an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories way TK
team that would make her a better
princess of wealth because you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 50